ça fait sanitaires et olivier ferrand
qui va donc s'exprimer cet après-midi
pour détailler expliquer la stratégie du
gouvernement dans cette lutte contre le
coc vide est ce que pour vous elles
manquent de clarté cette stratégie
gouvernementale
quand je pense qu'on peut le dire avec
une certaine évidence depuis le début
elle manque de clarté manque de
cohérence
nous l'avons vu sur la question des
masques qui tombent un sujet absolument
centrale qui a démontré à quel point le
gouvernement ne savait pas où ils
allaient et d'ailleurs vous savez si
aujourd'hui on a une telle contestation
sur la question du port du masque
généralisée il faut comprendre d'où ça
vient ça vient pas d'un complotisme
ambiance ça vient aussi du fait que les
mêmes dirigeants qui aujourd'hui nous
explique que le port du masque est
absolument d'impératifs hier nous
expliquer qu' il ne fallait surtout pas
le porter et donc cette incohérence de
la parole publique
elle a créé ce grand brouillon puis
aujourd'hui moi j'ai un vrai sujet avec
les tests depuis le début de cette crise
sanitaire tout le monde nous dit tout le
monde convient que les tests sont au
coeur la stratégie le ministre la santé
n'a pas cessé de le répéter et depuis
plusieurs mois nous nous rendons compte
que le pays n'est pas du tout organisé
pour permettre les tests à il faut être
très clair
vous l'avez peut-être vu avec certaines
vos proches aujourd'hui il faut attendre
dans des files d'attentes de 4 à 6
heures les uns contre les autres pour
bénéficier d'un test
il faut parfois plusieurs jours pour
obtenir le résultat du test ce qui fait
que c'est totalement inefficace la
priorisation dont parle jean castex vous
ayez être favorable j'imagine a bien sûr
mais ça fonctionne pas ça fonctionne pas
depuis 48 heures on voit que ça marche
pas voyez les files d'attentes
parisienne voyez en province moi je le
constate y compris dans ma région
les laboratoires sont absolument
débordées notre pays a été incapable de
s'organiser
c'est ça la vérité la vérité c'est que
ce gouvernement a été incapable de
mettre en place une stratégie à la
hauteur de ses moyens il a été incapable
depuis le début de cette crise sanitaire
de faire en sorte que nous ayons
notamment des techniques de test
nouvelle pas écouté nous sommes dans une
grande nation une grande puissance
mondiale
moi je trouve invraisemblable pardon de
le dire que depuis le début de cette
crise on n'ait pas trouvé d'autre
solution de test que le test par le
prélèvement nasal qui pose des problèmes
enfin on a quand même un grand pays qui
auraient pu réfléchir à ces questions
s'organiser l'état aurait pu mobiliser
des moyens pour nous ayons cette
capacité de recherche et d'innovation et
quant à l'organisation opérationnelle
je suis désolé mais ce gouvernement
parle beaucoup jean castex vous fait des
grandes phrases qu'il faut aller étudier
dans votre pays
deux sentiments grave celui de la
désespérance
je pense que notre pays désespère toutes
les catégories sociales toutes les
générations n'ont plus de cap n'ont plus
de raisons d'espérer un avenir meilleur
et ça c'est dramatique dans une
démocratie comme la nôtre est ma
deuxième source d'inquiétude c'est ce
sentiment d'injustice profond
personne ne peut contester aujourd'hui
que nous avons une question sur les
salaires dans notre pays personne ne
peut contester aujourd'hui que nous
avons une vraie question sur les
injustices sociales dans notre pays et
si nous ne traitons pas si le politique
ne traite pas cette question du manque
d'espérance du manque d'espoir et de
cette présence trop forte de l'injustice
alors nous allons vers l'explosion
sociale l'autre défiance qu'on peut qu
on peut noter monsieur bradier c'est le
sentiment des français que l'état ne
peut plus rien faire contre les plans
sociaux
on l'a vu avec auchan nokia et au hyères
bridgestone est ce qu'on est condamné à
avoir des plans sociaux sans pouvoir
réagir c'est aussi sûrement une des
grandes raisons de désespérance dans
notre pays c'est cette forme de fatalité
depuis deux ans la politique n'a pas
changé la vie de nos concitoyens
depuis très longtemps depuis quatre ans
la politique n'a pas été capable de dire
que ceux qui n'étaient pas acceptables
devait être transformée et emmanuel
macron incarne ce fatalisme font ils à
cette vision qui consiste à dire que le
politique est là pour accompagner une
marche quasi évidente du monde la
mondialisation et ses injustices les
écarts de salaire et ses injustices
la concentration des richesses entre
certaines fortunes et l'écart entre les
premiers de corvée et et les autres bref
emmanuel macron il y là pour être
spectateur de cette installation d
injustice et de cette fatalité notamment
sur les plans sociaux mais je crois que
là aussi un des grands chemins de
responsabilité pour la droite c'est de
réincarner ce que nous avons toujours
historiquement un carnet c'est à dire un
volontarisme politique